foreign
[Music]
the future of databases for generative
AI a topic for the time certainly hello
everyone my name is Shailesh
krishnamurthy I'm VP engineering for
databases at Google cloud and I couldn't
be more excited to be with all of you
here again in person at Google next
thank you all for coming we are
fortunate to have two amazing industry
leaders today to share the stage Gil
Perez who's the chief Innovation officer
of Deutsche Bank and Mohit saxena
co-founder and group CTO of inmobi Gill
and Mohit will share their very own
unique perspective on this important
topic
so with the Advent of gen AI we are
seeing perhaps what's the biggest and
the fastest reimagination and
reinvention of Enterprise apps in recent
memory so the first topic will be about
the specific and unique challenges that
these applications must surmount in
order to be successful
now the heart of every application is
actually an operational database and
transactional database so the second
topic will be how your oltp databases
are the critical ingredient the secret
ingredient to success for Enterprise gen
AI applications
and we are not just advancing databases
and empowering our customers we're also
eating our own dog food so we'll get
into how we at Google are leveraging gen
AI in order to improve all our managed
products and in particular we're really
looking to fundamentally simplify data
management
so let's get started with these
Enterprise dnai challenges
now the last year has been fascinating
we've all seen a whole bunch of really
interesting user experiences with Gen AI
you know we've had text and image
generation immersive collaboration we've
had magical search experiences now
although we've experienced all of this
in the consumer space I think what's
interesting is that Enterprise space
Genia is poised to fundamentally
transform customer experiences and
increase productivity
so what's really fascinating is that
genei is heralding a new post-training
era large language models llms are
democratizing Ai and they are making it
fundamentally accessible to application
developers application developers do not
anymore need to learn how to train deep
learning models they don't need to
become proficient in linear algebra
sling matrices around application
developers are already positioned to
drive Innovation today with generative
AI
and according to the Bureau of Labor
Statistics in the U.S there are over 10
times the number of software developers
as compared to data scientists that's an
order of magnitude more Innovation
potential that software developers can
bring to the table with generative AI
now our heroes uh you know application
developers are looking to use the power
of llms to weave new genii driven
experiences in their existing and new
applications
but that's a challenge LMS by themselves
are not enough that's because Enterprise
General applications need to you know
provide the most accurate and up-to-date
information they need to offer relevant
context sensitive user experiences and
most of all they need to be easy and a
pleasure to develop build and operate
and you know this is where databases
enter the chat so to speak but memes
aside we believe that databases with
Vector indexing support can bridge the
gap between your llms and your genei
applications
here's how first databases provide the
most accurate the most real time the
most current information so your old DP
databases can be used to retrieve
information to augment your llm prompts
and what that lets you do is ground your
llms for accuracy and relevance so app
Enterprise generate applications that
combine llms with operational databases
can provide the most accurate answers
based on real-time data
second
database is stored in addition to
structured data lots and lots of
unstructured data these could include
things like product descriptions catalog
information images help desk tickets
support cases you know chat messages
usage and related content you name it
and llms have risen to very powerful
embedding models that can be used to
encode the semantic meaning of
unstructured data in Vector in numeric
Vector representation now you can store
and index these vectors right in your
database you can query them with
approximate nearest neighbor predicates
for semantic search based queries and
most powerful of all you can combine
both regular predicates on structured
data with the semantic search predicates
on unstructured data that lets you build
a whole new kind of application you can
you can certainly build immersive
semantic search applications
but you can also find the most relevant
subset of your information to send your
llms and that lets you really build very
magical history based conversations so
there are a lot of very interesting
things that can be done with Vector
indexing especially when that Vector
indexing is right in your database when
you don't have to deal with a whole new
data stack
and finally you can do all of this with
the data that's right in your database
your databases are your most trusted
data store they are you know at the
heart of your mission critical line of
business applications they provide for
you Best in Class availability
reliability scalability safety data
Protection security performance latency
it's what you've come to expect it's
what you need it's not something you can
compromise with and for your application
developers databases are at the heart of
a thriving and robust ecosystem you know
your developers love your visual IDE
experiences you have idiomatic client
Library bindings in the languages of
your choice and and of course you have
orm tools and the list goes on and best
of all your application developers and
your operational Engineers they are all
intimately familiar with databases
already they don't need to try out a new
untested untried stack and figure out
how to populate the data there and
hydrate that data you know you don't
need to figure out another set of slos
you can do it right there in the systems
that you already know and love and so we
are bringing this technology across our
managed databases portfolio starting
with alloy DB AI which is an awesome
database built for Enterprise gen AI
applications a low ADB AI provides you
know high performance PG Vector
compatible
Vector indexing and search which is 10
times faster than standard postgres
provides easy to use and highly
efficient embedding generation right
from within your database and it works
with the vertex AI ecosystem and the
much wider open source genetic gen AI
ecosystem so we are extremely excited
about our idb
now I want to welcome my colleague Gill
Perez who's the chief Innovation officer
of deutschebag Gail and his team have
been advancing AIML for over three years
you're well ahead of the code well
before the dnai hype it's a fascinating
story and you're going to love it thank
you
thank you everybody and great to be here
um
let me start off with a quick overview
of our journey which actually started in
2020 with a strategic partnership that
if you want to think about it a year
before that we went through a strategy
of trying to consolidate our view of how
do we go from what we call before a
private Cloud to the public Cloud so we
basically had a whole transformation of
deciding our path forward the strategy
that ended up with with selecting Google
as our provider and signing a 10 and a
half year partnership with them
and in essence that started our Cloud
journey in more Earnest which continues
all the way to today and and will
continue in the following years but
while we were doing that the first year
ended up being uh 2021 ended up being
the year what we call Regulatory and
control Frameworks as a regulated
industry we cannot just move things to
the cloud
we have to actually get more than 46
Regulators to approve to validate and
only when all of that is ticked and
approved can we start moving any kind of
workload to the cloud so you can imagine
all of the uh back and forth with all
those entities it took us about a year
to get our MVP of that and that's
obviously an evolving element because
regulations change new requirements come
up and so it's a constant Evolution as
well so thank think of that as a basic
foundations that we need to deal with as
a regulated entity
and while we were doing all of that
we have a term called NBT next big thing
and while we were doing this Foundation
we said we have to also focus on the
next big thing and in 2021 we decided
that it's going to be AIML and at the
time we also identified another partner
that were were extremely delighted to
see them here today on on on stage with
Thomas but we are identified at the time
Nvidia as a key partner and began
working actually uh quite closely with
Jensen and with his team on how would Ai
and gen AI at the time it was
Transformers spinformers all kinds of
other things that just basic uh no NLP
how did they come into the world of
financial regulated Industries
and we in essence began that in 2021
2022 was the year that we've actually
engaged our businesses
and went out to all of our business and
started Gathering use cases I can say
that that year was you know the the
reception that we we received was not oh
this is amazing let's change the world
it was lukewarm it was like oh this is
great this is some kind of cool
technology nobody really uh really
understood uh the potential that all
changed obviously when chat GPT
entered the scene and from basically the
end of 2020 uh two we've seen a huge
change in the reaction of the business
and if you think about you know we're
here in a developer concerts conference
we're talking about all kinds of
different things but the most important
thing that has happened regenerative AI
is really the fact that businesses want
to transform their practices they're
willing to engage in redefining the way
they do their business which is a
fundamental difference than trying to
say hey I've got a technology it could
it does things better faster trying to
convince the business and obviously with
that kind of excitement from the
business and all the way to the top of
our company
our AI mL of 2023 was launched
um
and
this is really a a short overview of the
different things that we're doing but if
if
there's obviously an ongoing discovery
that we're doing with all of the
businesses and it's very important to
ensure that this kind of Discovery
becomes a a standard practice into the
organization because we look at
generative AI as really in re in the
early phases we're going to learn a lot
new use cases are going to pop up all
the time you really need to get the
organization
and specifically the business engage
with you there's all kinds of other
topics I like to jump really to the
bottom there which is from my
perspective really important we've also
engaged on
engaging with the with the users on how
to use
AI in the organization what does it mean
responsible Ai and we we embarked on a
summer of AI which was a huge effort
throughout all of DB ended up with a
24-hour hackathon with 1700 teams sorry
1700 participants about 210 teams which
we got a huge amount of of Engagement
and lots of ideas and and really all of
that together is is nurturing our our
collaboration with the business but more
important we also while we did all that
we also went top down
and the top down view was looking at the
skill sets that from each one of the use
cases that we have so let let me take
and you'll probably go and and see our
showcase on on the show floor
um code generation uh code writing duet
AI we've actually looked at each one of
our use cases and broke it down to
skills we then map those skills to our
HR taxonomy to the job descriptions and
in essence created a heat map of where
do we see the most the groups that would
be impacted the most by these kind of
changes so in essence we went and
created a top view of the organization
and we have a very clear understanding
of the areas one of them is obviously
the code generation where we have 8 000
people 8 000 developers that are right
now working day in and day out and we
obviously believe that uh that use case
will be fundamentally changed us
moreover if it does continue forward we
obviously believe that it will have a
profound impact on
the business developers because we do
see the the natural progression of the
development tools and making them and
the citizen we call them the citizen gen
AI developer will become a part of the
fabric of our organization last but not
least I wanted to put this uh and to
share this with you
um this is at a high level R kind of
view or stack of generative Ai and I
wanted to focus on the orchestration
layer because that is the layer that
we're spending a whole lot of time on
that is where the Lang chain uh comes in
that's where we we get the prompt or the
query from the end user break it up to
sometimes going to a database sometimes
going to a search obviously going to an
llm creating the prompt that goes down
to the
um to the llm coming back reconstructing
the
um the result and then serving it up it
back so that entire orchestration layer
is extremely uh powerful and we're
spending a lot of our time on it
obviously there's different layers to
the bottom uh including the the large
language models and the data but we're
right now starting first of all to try
to optimize that level without
trying to do the training we're getting
to the limitations but with every new
large language model that we're trying
we're seeing new capabilities obviously
we were mentioned today over a hundred
large language models are now available
I think we're going to have a very
interesting
next year or so two years of figuring
out what is the optimal size of large
language models do you go with an
all-purpose one do you go with smaller
ones how do you construct them do you go
when and in the orchestration layer
Federate to a distributed a large
language query to multiple large
language models bring them up back
together go back again there's all kinds
of techniques that are are evolving and
I think that it's going to be a very
interesting area I think that that
orchestration layer is going to be a lot
of ipn let's not forget that
orchestration layer is also very
dependent on your data and the structure
so
last but not least I I want to end up
with with one comment
um and that's another uh Insight that we
have that we view prompting as IP
intellectual property
and so I think that
um just doing a mindset for the
organization that everything that goes
into the uh to this kind of a stack and
comes out you should think about it as
your own IP is is uh the right thing to
do because that really captures a lot of
the the knowledge and the capabilities
that you have you could use all of that
data later on to making recommendations
of prompts
um you can figure out which prompts are
are applicable for certain people you
can also use it with lifecycle
management of of uh machine of large
language models so there's a whole lot
of things that could be derived from
that but again
the entire prompting as an IP and
capturing it is super important and with
that uh back to you
[Applause]
peace I think our friends in Sandhill
Road are already writing checks it's a
startup idea right there uh but but
thank you Gail I think one of the most
important things as engineering leaders
is balancing Innovation for the future
and paying our bills so it's really
great to see see how Tasha bank has done
that
um I I want to move to the next section
of the top and talk about how databases
are uh you know critical part of
building these applications and Gil just
mentioned orchestration and I think
that's where I'm going to focus now so
in in this new world of gen AI
applications uh you have to orchestrate
between many different things you have
your embedding models that provide
numeric Vector representations of uh
your unstructured data you have these
embedding models are much more efficient
than large language models which are
actually trained on large internet
corpora and you know they can predict
future words based on on a prompt and of
course our very own Superstars right
operational databases real-time
operational databases relational and
non-relational databases
so I'm going to talk about three kinds
of orchestration scenarios one where you
only have embedding models you don't
even have llaps we think these are
really valid gen AI applications
orchestration scenarios where you only
have llms and one and finally when you
have both embedding models and llms so
the context for uh what I'm what we're
going to walk through is uh simple games
a hypothetical uh online B2B SAS gaming
platform for whose customers are various
indie game studios uh they they host uh
consumer games on this platform for uh
you know people on on the web and on the
mobile ecosystems
so let's start with the first scenario
so in this case we are trying to help a
support engineer triage a support case
and identified duplicates so you know
let's take you know a support case comes
in someone is complaining that a given
game is is really you know slow on
Startup and what what we're what the
engineers trying to do is figure out
quickly is this a known issue or is this
a new issue and you really need to
leverage the current state of the system
so the first step is you call an
embedding model and you generate a
vector representation of uh you know of
of the issue then you go probe that your
database and you probe it with a simple
straightforward SQL query where you're
Computing this approximate nearest
neighbor you're trying to find the most
similar uh bugs that exist in the system
but note the the predicate that's in
blue b dot status equals open you're
trying to limit the search to the actual
open bugs so this gets the power of
going against the real-time system you
have your operational system you have
the current state of your system you
know what your current bugs are and you
are now trying to find which are the
most relevant Buffs and you get that set
of results you know from the system and
now uh the support engineer can eyeball
that list and try to figure out if this
is a known bug maybe they add an
annotation in that and otherwise they
create a new bug
so let's recap what did we see in this
scenario we saw the use of similarity
search in an integrated fashion along
with in many ways it's similar to full
text search which databases have had but
the real Power is coming because you're
integrating the information in your
structured data you're looking at the
latest and greatest data you're looking
at the current state of the system it's
very hard to to have this kind of user
experience if you are a vector indexing
is happening somewhere else so the
integration is is one big part the
second big part is the power of
embeddings because of llms embeddings
have become this extremely powerful tool
I think this is going to be transmitted
for the database industry it's going to
go beyond unstructured data in the
future I predict we'll be talking about
embeddings for structured data I think
when you think about entity relationship
modeling you'll start to think about
embeddings as almost the Primitive for
every entity I think it's really going
to change our world so we should keep
our eye on it
now let's move to the next scenario
where we're only going to use large
language models so in this case the
scenario is to help a support engineer
generate an email to a customer by
leveraging what we know about incident
reports so we start with an instruction
about writing an email and all we have
is a given incident ID now in order to
actually write that email you need to
get more information so the first step
is you programmatically build a prompt
and the prompt includes you know the
instruction to the llm so note that this
prompt is not generated by a user it's
actually a programmer an engineer an
application developer who has written
this up front but this prompt has a
bunch of parameters that's why it's a
template and it needs to know the you
know incident description when it
started when it ended the impacted
resources and how we do how do we get
that by running a query on our
Superstars the operational database so
you run a standard SQL query you fetch
all of the information you need and you
augment The Prompt template and now you
are having the recipe for the llm you
tell the llm generator user facing
impact statement omit internal technical
details provide all of the additional
details and just like magic the llm
generates the email right it says
something like your game ABC that
involves this set of resources was down
from 6 AM to 8 AM because of a network
connectivity issue now
let's face it this is not an RCA this is
just uh you know just an email and maybe
that's a good thing right we don't want
the AI to take all our jobs we have some
job security right writing a good RCA so
but it's a stack this is where you know
the the AI helps us and of course we
might want to save all of this
communication history in a database
presumably we'll create a vector index
uh on the message and we'll talk about
that in the in the final use case so
what did we do here uh we had these
three steps we had retrieval where you
fetch data from the database
augmentation where you augmented The
Prompt and finally generation where the
llm you know generated text rag the rack
pattern it's a new hotness the way this
industry is going we'll probably have 10
more new patterns in the next two months
but for now rag is it but I want to talk
about something else here
um you know I know I'm dating myself but
what this what I'm reflecting when I
look at this pattern is I go back in
time a quarter Century back uh you know
many of us in the room we're building
database backed web applications you
know uh can anyone say Java server Pages
active server pages so what what were we
doing then we built programmatically we
built HTML templates we query the
database we stack those values in those
HTML templates and we returned HTML to
the clients what we are doing is not
that different we're building prompt
templates programmatically uh you know
augmenting them with data retrieved from
the database and we are sending them to
their lab yes we are doing something new
but we're also doing something that us
this community that builds you know
database backed applications we know how
to do this llms are not some crazy idea
now we've got this we know how to build
these applications so you know we should
look forward to embracing llms in
database backed applications
so the final scenario I'm going to talk
about where you combine both embedding
models and lnms in this scenario we are
you know saying we want to support help
support Engineers respond to chat
messages in real time and we want to
leverage the past history so you get a
chat message customers complaining hey
this game is slow is it the same as the
networking issue from the past now what
we want to do is again as before build
that prompt template programmatically
but what you want to do is get the prior
context and this is where the accuracy
the relevance comes in if I just include
all the chat messages from the past for
that particular customer it may be too
much we will overwhelm the llm in an
avalanche of data so what we want to do
is find the most relevant chat messages
from the past history and we do that
with a vector query you have a query the
same idea you take you map that the the
user information into Vector
representation using an embedding model
we probe the database and you find you
know the set of similar queries and in
this case you add an extra predicate and
limited to the last month but you could
maybe look at the last year or the last
week as you choose and then you have
another query an independent query where
you find this current set of open
incidents you take all of that you
package that into the prompt template
and you send it to the llm right and now
the llm actually responds like magic and
it actually says something like we are
currently dealing with two open
incidents a capacity stock issue and a
tail latency spike in in storage but
none of these issues seem relevant to to
your networking issue that you
experienced you experience in August
28th so this is personalized you have
grounded it and you also given the llm
relevance
so let's recap again what we are seeing
here is a pattern which we call
long-term memory for large language
models
and you know there's always the
straight-off you can you know tune the
llms you can train them but you need to
get the most relevant information and
you want to get that private information
from your database and you know one of
the the challenges when you deal with
llms is that they have prompt limits you
can't send uh you know problems which
are of unlimited length and the second
issue especially there's some very
recent research is llms tend to look at
the early part of the prompt more so the
smaller the prompt the better you should
avoid sending too much information and
so that's why the vector indexing is
really key and that's what people mean
when they talk about long-term memory
so finally thus far I gave a very
database-centric view of orchestration
but that's another view right there's a
view not that you're coming in from a
database back tab there's a view where
I'm actually coming into the llm first
and so then the question is how is that
llm going to ground itself uh and you
know we are announcing uh vertex AI is
announcing an extensions model
extensions really are a standard way for
an llm to create queries for an external
API databases just another external API
and what we are announcing is a database
specific retrieval plugin retrieval
extension for Alloy DB and what this
will let you do is in this world the llm
will be prompted with the description of
the API it generates query parameters
sends it to the query service which runs
a query sends the results back for the
next step in your chain uh the nice
thing in all of this is the framework
will support built-in robust identity
and authentication to enable secure
access to private data and with that
it's my distinct pleasure and honor to
invite my friend Mohit Mohit saxena as
the co-founder and group CTO of in Mobi
but today he's going to talk about
glance which is a startup that's taken
in the world by storm I guess you're not
a startup anymore right yeah all right
thanks
thank you guys
um I think it's a privilege to be here
representing uh in Moby group and glance
and in fact I have my co-founder and
team member here also who have their own
subsequent session uh so before I begin
let me introduce you to uh in Bobby
group and uh
we are
founded in 2000
through our various product our reach is
around 2.4 billion smartphone uh some
number as you can see we are globally
very dispersed from Europe us and North
America and uh even in Asia
we are backed by some of the Marquee
customer and Google is one of them
SoftBank shall follow and some of the
gnomes names that are very familiar to
you guys but for this session I'll Focus
my conversation around glance which is
our b2c offering uh and glances are
basically uh in the business of
Revolution revolutionizing uh smart
surfaces as we know it today
so grants has also making some big
inroad in
2022 we have made big uh you know growth
in Asia and in 2023 we are making a road
towards the westward from Europe and in
North America uh we have roughly 450
million devices uh on this product uh
daily active user is somewhere around
200 million users enormous 20 plus
minute engagement time from user and
roughly 60 percent of the user uh are
with us with the NIT time Horizon which
is a significant number if you know the
b2c context here uh so what the way we
use a Smart surface today only as a
conduit to accessing some app you know
most of the things are restricted
anything you want to do utility and all
you just click and you go over there
what we are trying to Envision in glass
is can this surface be used to basically
have completely different line and
anticipatory Discovery a total
Serendipity that you know which is built
around you and that is what really
trying to do so the three main surfaces
that we are talking about is obviously
lock screen home screen which is the
screen that you go in after unlocking
your phone and the last one is foda
where your information is organized in
certain categories you know like Finance
shopping Etc
in glass what we are trying to do is a
snackable glanceable information that
that that is Meaningful to you you know
what is happening when is rain going to
happen you know when the rain is going
to stop and you know something you
follow San Francisco uh Niners and you
know what is happening on their score is
there a touchdown there is something
live event happening you know maybe Ed
Sheeran is in the town and he's doing
something so all the information that
you know that you care about and
something that is you know has a
significant value just in time uh you
know you can actually use this surface
uh to uh pop that out and interact with
that so that is really what glass is
trying to do bringing live internet uh
to you on the three surfaces that I was
talking about
and we are not stopping a removal
because you know the surface is a
Surface even glass even TV is like a
large smartphone so why can't you know
that dull wallpaper can bring to you
know we can why can't we bring that
wallpaper into life and it gives you
important information that you care
about same thing in all utility games
you snippet that basically you know you
really care about so that's the vision
uh and for engineers in this room this
is how the stat looks like you know you
know there is an odm there is a OS there
is a chipset and then so far you know
the ecosystem on top of it which is
various app possibly you will be using
in your life as well and we see it right
in between them as a link where we uh
integrate between the app and the things
that are happening at a lower
programming level so it's a really you
know a bridge that is bringing all the
native utilities and Native features to
you in form of uh you know these
applications without downloading those
application on your three smart surfaces
so what is glass and what is glass
database you know if you are in the
business of delivering happiness to User
it's it's not easy job it's really hard
you know making user happy is is it
takes a lot of work and if you think
about it we have been using databases to
basically deliver that value and
happiness out there but database have a
long Evolution cycle you know it started
with rdbms storing transaction and then
we got into media we got into other kind
of documents and this has become very
fragmented you know for every kind of
asset you have a different database
where you store all those kind of things
so the bigger challenges in Mobile where
everything has to be time-bound and
everything has to be you know at a very
high throughput lot of computation
happen at the runtime where you have to
pull multiple assets and figure out what
is the most important and relevant thing
for for us and that is lot of
computation and that is really you know
uh what the what the challenge glance
faces on day-to-day basis because your
happiness or your relevant content could
be an Edge
it could be a gaming it could be a live
it could be shopping
it could be live content it could be
short videos it could be news it could
be anything
and we have to figure out what are those
three four five ten things that that are
most relevant around you so what we are
doing is basically running multiple
models browsing through all these assets
and then doing Federated ranking on top
of that so that you can we can deliver
to you what makes uh most meaning uh um
which is most meaningful to you so that
is really the challenge that we are
facing at the glance
and
we moved all some of our Legacy system
into spanner most recently and and our
requirement always is availability
scalability and consistency and you you
can see some of the throughput that we
deal with is roughly 3000 requests per
second and this migration was so
astounding in terms of saving and
performance that my colleague is
presenting a session on the migration
itself I think Google next uh but after
that our North Star is basically we
shouldn't be doing so much computation
on top of it if my database can
understand the semantics and it can it
can put that semantic context along with
the asset then a huge step is going to
go out from our life and we can just
focus on what we do best delivering
happiness to our user you know what is
it could be three images two short
videos five news article whatever it is
you know the context should be
understood by the system and everything
the information is Right stored in there
so that is really what we are trying to
go after this is a pretty interesting
image and there is a story to it I think
you have seen in the image that Shailesh
was showing and when I was talking to
him about the session I didn't see his
image and and my Engineers came up with
this image and basically two things got
very clear to me number one great mind
thinks alike so we were building a
similar image what he was thinking and
the second thing is this is this was so
real to the problem that we were
grappling you know this is really what
our design is we have operational data
basis on one side and we were trying to
figure out the semantic and contextual
relevancy around it and then llm running
on top of it so imagine basically if the
vector emerging Vector databases uh and
in assets and core information is stored
together a huge step from our life will
go away immediately and we can start
focusing focusing on what we do best
which is making our user Happy by having
this discovery and and showing them the
information that matter to them in
timely manner
with that I think shalish I will hand
you over that
[Applause]
thank you so much Mohit that was uh that
was that was really fascinating uh you
know what a ride I think it's it's we've
enjoyed working together I think we've
brought a massive production system uh
you you know that migration story is
really awesome totally encourage you all
uh to go attend it and and I think we
are also learning so much from your
experiences so thank you for the
partnership
uh I I want to now uh spend the rest of
the time talking about how we at Google
Cloud are also eating our own dog food
uh we are an application too
star uh services and you know our
managed uh Cloud databases we have a
control plane we have a data plane we
for offer apis and so we can also
leverage jnai in our own applications
and uh dramatically simplify data
management
and we're doing that using duet AI uh in
Google Cloud it's the AI powered always
on collaborator uh and in Duet Ai and
databases in particular has you know
three big things the first is a chat
interface a natural language chat
interface let's write in the console
that's providing the information you
need in the context that you needed you
can ask specific questions based on
where you are the second is an assistive
programming interface right in the cloud
console that is going to you know
provide a SQL based code generation and
code completion we'll have we'll extend
it to other models uh you know it's it's
going to be an experience which is which
is going to be delightful and and help
help programmers and help developers and
the third is really help for automated
database migration uh you know the in
particular it's going to focus on the
last mile assistance to help you all
migrate from Legacy commercial databases
so let's talk about a couple of these
things uh first duet Ai and Cloud
spanner we'll also be following so this
I think we're going to be branded
Spanish Studio it's in preview we'll be
following this in Cloud SQL and in in
other systems uh but the basic user
experience is right in your console in a
comment you can start having uh you know
natural language description it's going
to give you uh Auto generation Auto
completion fix it and a lot of cool
things I think this particular example
on screen uh you're trying to ask about
uh some churn analysis or something like
that and you know you put in the comment
it you know provides the text it's
really cool I mean you know you're going
to love it I was playing with it the
other day you know I put in you know
just for fun comment that said you know
create a table uh to model restaurants
you know it came up with a bunch of
interesting things Cuisine and other
things then I said you know populate
this table with a bunch of with 10 dummy
rows and it you know does a whole bunch
of interesting things it only picked
fast food chains but then to be fair I
didn't ask her to pick Commission Star
Restaurant so you know it actually works
really well it's really fun uh you know
to see to see that actually in practice
uh and and the interesting thing again
is it didn't take a lot of work for us
to build this this is where it is again
what I'm trying to say we didn't have to
do training we have past training we're
just able to Leverage The llms and
deliver you know that value right there
so super exciting uh and and then the
database migration service so DMS is
this amazing service that we are using
uh our customers are telling us how they
hate uh operating in the Legacy
commercial databases were it's painful
they want to come to you know the high
performance High scale vibrant uh
postgres ecosystem and so we are helping
them on that Journey database migration
service you know already takes care of
many of the very hard things you have to
do schema conversion you have to move
the data to replicate the data but you
know one real bug bear is stored
procedures any of you who are in Legacy
shops will see you know you know tens of
thousands of lines hundreds of thousands
of lines we have customers who have four
or five million lines of code in store
procedures you need to move all of that
and so we are providing you know this
these built-in tools to move them well
one of the big challenges is this last
mile problem uh you know as best as the
tools are they don't solve all the
problems that's where a human being
enters the loop and what is really cool
and how we've used duet AI here is as
you're going and fixing these problems
the llm like magic will come and say hey
I see you made this change there's 200
other changes that are very similar
shall we make them for you boom you're
in business right so I'm incredibly
excited about database migration service
and in fact about all of our duet AI we
are just getting started there's you
know a whole host of interesting
Innovation we're going to keep
delivering it and you know we it's it it
helps us learn the patterns how we're
doing it I think will also help you all
uh you know not just make benefit from
how we are simplifying data management
but we are excited at sharing these
patterns so that you can all use them in
building your own you know your own
applications
so uh where do we go from here first
again I want to reiterate the immense
potential in generative AI I know we've
all looked at the chat Bots and other
experiences but I think you know for us
uh as Engineers I think the big value is
to Leverage The real-time data that's in
your operational database to put it all
together with Google's history and
Innovation AI we have an amazing
Foundation I like to paraphrase Newton
if we can see farther it's because we
stand on the shoulder of Giants and and
that's that's what Google's
infrastructure give for gives for us we
have you know the world's best
operational database the best analytics
systems and really amazing and vibrant
uh AI ecosystem all of that can be put
together to really build a unified data
and AI platform for the next generation
of applications
you know I encourage you all to get
started uh you know we have a lot of
resources in how you can learn and
workshops that you can use uh if you
have interesting ideas I think every
time I speak with a new customer in this
world we're getting 10 new ideas
um you know everything that I said in my
scenarios they all came from customers
real customers whom I talk to right I
mean I kind of paraphrase this into our
simple games example but it really came
with engagement so I value the
engagement it's a gift for us uh and you
know if you know if you have ideas
please come and find me I'd love to chat
uh and of course you know also with our
account teams uh you know please you
know reach out to our Professional
Services Partners you can start building
um and you know first again thank you
all to my co-presenters first you know
you know amazing job thank you so much
and thank you all you've been an amazing
and wonderful audience I'm glad we're
all back in person uh please uh send us
your feedback
thank you